ici deux fois par jour à marée basse une
petite armée de femmes rentrent dans
l'eau pour y ramasser le sable
au cap vert
elles sont surnommés les voleuses de
sable des heures durant elle répète
inlassablement les mêmes gestes
l'eau est très froide ans
vous
suzie descend sur la plage six jours sur
sept depuis l'âge de 12 ans elle marche
dans les pas de sa mère et de toutes les
femmes de son village
je me sens triste parce que c'était une
belle plage elle est détruite parce que
nos ventres sont vides
c'est comme ça depuis longtemps
depuis l'époque de mes grands parents
bon
aujourd'hui c'est mauvais il y en a très
peu
bayat aujourd'hui c'est vraiment mauvais
[Musique]
les bassines que les femmes charge sur
leurs têtes peuvent peser jusqu'à 50
kilos
ce soir elles ont fait chacune une
dizaine d'allers retours pour une demi
tonne de sable déplacés
[Musique]
sur cette plage chaque monticule
correspond au travail de deux voire
trois ramasseuse celui là c'est un bon
sable située à 700 km au large du
sénégal le cap vert ne possède aucune
ressource naturelle excepté l'or noir de
ces îles volcaniques
le sable est récent il est noir est beau
mais il ya beaucoup de cailloux
je suis en train de tamiser le sable
pour enlever les cailloux afin de
pouvoir le vendre
c'est important parce que personne ne
nous l'achètera comme ça
[Musique]
suzy et les autres femmes ne termineront
leur travail harassant qu'à la nuit
tombée
[Musique]
l'exploitation illégale de sable sévit
depuis les années 70 la raison le boom
immobilier sur l'archipel
chaque jour des constructions
anarchiques poussent un peu partout
souvent grâce à l'argent envoyé par la
diaspora capverdienne des constructions
réalisées principalement avec le sable
des plages
[Musique]
quartier pauvre de santa cruz ici pas
d'eau potable et de l'électricité selon
quelques heures par jour c'est ici
qu'habitent suzy entre quatre murs de
fortune elle élève seule ses trois
enfants est une guerrière
c'est grâce à son travail que j'étudie
malgré la fatigue elle n'a jamais
abandonné car son seul but est de voir
ses enfants étudient c'est très
important pour moi qu'ils aillent à
l'école pour qu'ils ne fassent pas le
même travail que moi c'est un meilleur
futur et qu'il devienne une personne
différente de moi la plupart des femmes
qui font ce travail sont celles qui
n'ont pas des de la part des pères de
leurs enfants une femme qui a le soutien
à 100% de la part du père de ses enfants
n'auraient pas la nécessité de ramasser
du sable car c'est un travail
dévalorisant
on travaille très dévalorisant un
travail dévalorisant et usant
j'ai 35 ans aujourd'hui et j'ai le corps
d'une personne de 70 ans
je suis tout casser j'ai mal partout au
dos aux jambes au genou le soir quand
c'est l'heure de dormir
mon corps refroidi et la douleur se
réveille
[Musique]
suzie n'est pas un cas isolé tout se
plaignent des mêmes douleurs pour
remplir une remorque de camion
les femmes savent qu'il faut déplacer et
tamisée 70 bassine de sable soit presque
quatre tonnes de matières premières
un travail qui peut parfois prendre
plusieurs semaines ce matin le
chargement de suzy est prêt elle
contacte un constructeur avec lequel
elle fait régulièrement affaire cette
usine est ce que tu as besoin de sable
je viens de tout changer quoi deux
chargements à quelle heure tu viens je
suis ravi j'ai hâte qu'il soit 7 heures
pour récupérer l'argent et que ses
charges et il me perd à cette heure je
serai là à l'attendre pour récupérer
l'argent
[Musique]
le constructeur sait que son activité
est illégal il viendra une fois la nuit
tombée et refusera la présence de notre
caméra
pour cette livraison suzy gagnera 30
euros qu'elle partagera avec sa soeur
ses revenus sont très variables selon
les mois mais en moyenne elles gagnent
deux fois moins que le salaire minimum
[Musique]
au cap vert une personne sur quatre vit
avec moins de 2 euros par jour
combien sont-elles à faire ce travail de
forçat il n'existe aucun chiffre
officiel
dans les nombreux villages côtiers les
hommes sont pêcheurs et agriculteurs et
les femmes ramassent le sable des femmes
de tout âge parfois même enceinte
et
en 2010 le gouvernement interdit cette
exploitation sauvage depuis des
militaires sont en faction jour et nuit
sur certaines plages pour dissuader les
voleuses les belles plages du cap vert
sont le plus grand atout du pays presque
5 millions de touristes viennent en
profiter chaque année une manne qui
représente près de 24% du pib mais pour
combien de temps encore
aujourd'hui certaines plages sont
complètement défiguré
des mines à ciel ouvert comme ici à
rincon sur l'île de santiago
je me sens mal qu'à l'époque il y avait
beaucoup de sable
nous avions aussi beaucoup de poissons
nous avons touché à ça et maintenant
nous sommes dans petra adélaïde et âgé
de 60 ans pendant des décennies elle a
participé à la destruction de la plage
de son village réputé à l'époque pour
son sable noir
il ne reste plus aujourd'hui que décalé
cette disparition du sable poussent
désormais certaines femmes à s'aventurer
toujours plus loin dans l'océan
on a eu peur quand tu es dans l'eau
parce que tu ne sais jamais à quel
moment tu sortiras et si tu en sortiras
comme tu es rentrée non marocains
voyez c'est comme ça que la mer ne
rejette un métier à haut risque
la plupart de ces femmes ne savent pas
nager adélaïde elle a décidé de
rapatrier ses outils à l'intérieur des
terres
[Musique]
c'est dangereux si sa tombe s'il est en
dessous la roche peut vous écrasez six
ans si la roche compte sur vous les bons
mais la première fois que je suis venu
une grosse pierre est tombé sur maison
et ça me les a arrachés
[Musique]
adélaïde exploiter ce filon depuis un an
la sexagénaire refuse qu'on la qualifie
de voleuse de sable si c'est un vol
pourquoi voler moi je considère pas que
je vole moi je ramasse sans me cacher je
le fais à la vue de tout le monde
moi je suis venu j'ai trouvé un endroit
où il y avait du sable je les ramasse et
j'ai demandé la permission à personne
s'ils veulent m'en d'empêcher ils
doivent me donner quelque chose d'autre
pour survivre mais je vais pas mourir de
favre
non
[Musique]
on va penser que je suis riche les gens
derrière leur télé vont croire que
toutes ces vaches sont à moi mais la
dame que vous voyez là elle n'a rien
[Musique]
il est 11 heures
adélaïde rentrer chez elle pour déjeuner
quand elle croise ses voisines la
conversation tourne toujours autour du
même sujet leurs conditions de travail
comment vous sentez vous je suis là nous
sommes comme les esclaves de sao tomé et
principe et qui était en chine et on
doit continuer puisque nous n'avons pas
le choix on doit faire avec
c'est notre destinée on nous a dit que
l' esclavage c'était fini on nous l'a
fait croire mais en regardant de plus
près ce n'est pas vrai si tu cherches
bien il est encore là il est étouffée il
est toujours présent oui si on cherche
bien l'esclavagé bien là mais on ne peut
plus vivre comme ça je ne peux plus
continuer je suis usé
[Musique]
une vie de misère aux conséquences
dramatiques pour l'environnement
ce géographe cap verdien on constate les
dégâts chaque jour
[Musique]
coincé face quand ils font l'extraction
de sable sur les plages
celles ci perdent leur protection
naturelle avec l'avancée de l'eau de mer
qui va s'infiltrer dans les sols
ça provoque une érosion qui est très
mauvaise pour l'environnement du
cap-vert et ça diminue les micro
organismes
il ya un manque de ces micro organismes
les poissons ne peuvent plus se
reproduire paix
après la plage le géographe nous emmène
un peu plus loin dans les terres pour
nous montrer les traces de cette
salinisation des cultures là au fond
d'la derrière les arbres mais il ya la
mer on peut voir les arbres comme les
cocotiers ici en faillite qui sont
amincies on voit que la terre est très
sèche et on peut apercevoir ici au pied
de cet arbre le sel l'influencent du sel
la couleur du sel en barre ici sur ce
cocotiers on peut vraiment voir tout ça
en cause la sécheresse mais surtout le
ramassage de sable
[Musique]
son exploitation impact aujourd'hui
profondément les plantations de la
vallée de santa cruz
[Musique]
les agriculteurs qui travaillent ne
peuvent que le déplorer comme josé pirès
dos santos l'eau est devenue sale et du
coup les bananes ne sont plus de bonne
qualité les tomates et les papayes non
plus c'est totalement différent d'un
endroit où l'eau est douce
lorsqu on les mange on sent la
différence
[Musique]
avant on voyait que cet endroit était
vers l'eau était abondante toutes les
activités et est immense mais la récolte
du sable a eu de grandes conséquences
avec le temps les plantations ont perdu
la valeur qu'elle avait de nombreux
agriculteurs ont abandonné leurs
plantations
[Musique]
le sable et la deuxième ressource
naturelle du monde la plus utilisée
après l'eau présents dans les
cosmétiques les ordinateurs les puces
électroniques
il est aussi le composant principal du
béton et c'est à ce titre qu'il est
utilisé au cap vert ici on trouve bien
du sable de carrière ou d'importation
mais il est nettement plus cher
[Musique]
elvis dirige des chantiers de
construction depuis 12 ans ce matin il
vient d'acheter du sable adena idées à
son petit fils donc j'ai rempli la
voiture et des normalement le prix de
120 euros
pas de place et 30 euros c'est pour ça
qu'on préfère le sable de madame
adélaïde parce qu'il ya une grande
différence de prix on est quittes
ah oui c'est ça problème ce sable parce
qu'il n'est pas traitée est de moins
bonne qualité bien sûr que le sable de
madame adélaïde n'est pas de la même
qualité que le sable officiel parce que
quand elle fait la récolte de son sable
il y a toujours un peu de terre dedans
et donc quand le sable est sale le
ciment perdre sa force et ça le rend
plus fragile des policiers était un
espace mêmes défauts avec le sable marin
mais là c'est le sel qui attaquent la
cie du béton armé le risque que les
maisons se fissure voir s'effondre ce
marché juteux reste totalement illégal
mais elvis assume
je n'ai absolument pas peur pas du tout
car je ne suis pas le seul à le faire
notre économie ne nous permet pas de
suivre les lois correctement ils ne
peuvent pas nous empêcher car l'état
c'est qu'il n'a pas les moyens il espère
jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de
procès contre le sable ramasser
[Musique]
la police censées veiller au grain
reconnaît qu'aujourd'hui stopper cette
exploitation sauvage n'est pas forcément
sa priorité
[Musique]
il est 16 heures à santa cruz deux
policiers sont envoyés en patrouille
leur but prendre en flagrant délit les
acteurs du trafic voleuse de saab au
constructeur
à partir de maintenant nous sommes en
approche de la plage de porto fundo il
faut repérer si des véhicules viennent
de là-bas
las quand on voit des voitures avec des
bâches on les arrête pour vérifier ici
nous sommes dans une zone critique dès
qu'on voit une voiture ou un camion on
les arrête pour les contrôler
mais aujourd'hui pas de véhicules
suspects arrêtés
s'arrête ici à l'arrivée des policiers
sur la plage les femmes s'enfuit
elles ont carrément fut mon frère les
deux fonctionnaires marche
tranquillement comme s'ils voulaient
leur laisser le temps de disparaître
quelle est encore frais en s'approchant
des monticules de sable
l'une d'entre elles est toujours là
bonjour bonjour ça va ça va est ce qu'un
des tas de sable et avoue oui
lequel est le vôtre madame les deux
dames isr lala sont les miens ok les
deux là bas vous ne savez pas que le
ramassage de sable c'est interdit on
sait que c'est interdit mais on n'a rien
d'autre
c'est pour ça qu'on vient vous n'avez
pas d'autres travaillent n'ont rien rien
depuis combien de temps vous ramassez le
sable ici moi depuis mes 12 ans je suis
dans la marée depuis l'âge de 12 ans
depuis votre enfance en fait depuis que
je suis petit
avec ma mère jusqu'à aujourd'hui ouais
ok mais vous étiez avec notre dame qui
ont fui oui on a vu la voiture arriver
et on a causé ok mais maintenant vous
devez nous accompagner jusqu'au
commissariat pour qu'on fait nos
empreintes
ok bah non je dois aller manger parce
que j'ai faim ce n'est pas une demande
c'est un autre vous avez
[Musique]
on
il avait compris oui j'ai bien compris
alors on y va
devant notre caméra les policiers se
sentent obligés de faire du zèle
[Musique]
j'en ai pleuré ce pas ce n'est pas la
peine de pleurer cette femme risque une
lourde amende entre 500 et 3000 euros
une somme qu'elle serait incapable de
payer même sur plusieurs années
[Musique]
c'est une fiche pour identifier la dame
on voit y inscrire toutes ces
informations dans votre nom s'il vous
plaît mariette vinas maria silvina
mettez vos empreintes ici gilles 13
février
vous arrêtez souvent des femmes
rarement très rarement on travaille
rarement avec des femmes ont marre est
surtout les voitures
les acheteurs eux risquent de 3000 40000
euros damende allait monter là
maintenant que je sais que vous arrêtez
je vais courir à fond la prochaine fois
je m'envolerai même s'il le faut compter
12 ans les policiers la ramèneront chez
elle quant à la mangue
c'est la mairie qui en fixera le montant
[Musique]
face à la volonté de l'état de mettre
fin à ce trafic les volumes de sable
refuse de se laisser faire et
s'organisent pendant de nombreux mois
elles n'ont cessé de demander de l'aide
aux autorités cet après midi la mairie
de santa cruz organise une réunion pour
répondre à leurs attentes
[Musique]
je suis persuadé que vous n'auriez pas
fait ce travail si vous aviez un emploi
la mairie vous propose un autre
programme qui consiste à élaborer un
projet personnalisé
celles qui ont de l'expérience dans
l'aviculture peuvent commander des
tuyaux du matériel d'irrigation un
moteur celles qui ont de l'expérience
dans l'élevage peuvent également avoir
un soutien pour les animaux le but c'est
que vous puissiez arrêté de ramasser du
sable santa cruz est la seule commune du
cap vert avoir décidé de mettre en place
un programme spécifique pour aider ces
femmes à se reconvertir à céder vous
avez beaucoup de femmes qui viennent
avec leurs enfants prendre le sable et
avec le temps leurs enfants sortent du
système scolaire poursuivre les mêmes
pas comme on dit chez nous il faut
couper le mal à la racine
mais c'est un long processus
ça ne va pas être facile
et fait face peut-être un espoir pour
suzy et ses amis
[Musique]
j'arrive à avoir le financement pour
pouvoir acheter des cochons aménager un
espace très mon business
ça me permettrait d'avoir un métier
souple pour avoir un peu de temps à
consacrer à mes enfants
oui on va dire que j'ai de l'espoir
[Musique]
j'espère que la mairie pourra nous aider
parce que nous ne sommes personne et
notre histoire est méconnue
[Musique]
la bonne volonté de la mairie n'y
suffira sans doute pas pour mener à bien
son projet manque toujours le feu vert
et surtout le financement du ministère
de l'environnement sans aucune garantie
les ramasseuses de sable pour survivre
continueront de courber l'échiné sur les
plages du cap vert
[Musique]